richie sunak you you've just stood here
and said boris johnson's a remarkable
person you don't want history to
demonize him but the fact is
that the parties just ousted him on the
basis of conduct probity and causing
division and here you are and i have to
put it to you that you have a police
fine over partygate and there have been
questions too
over your very wealthy family
avoiding paying millions of pounds in
tax due to your wife being a non-dom
taxpayer now that i know arrangement has
changed but that was until very recently
and i have to say you're an utterly
corrosive figure in the parliamentary
party for a big chunk of it so i put it
to you
i i have i i'm sorry but there are i am
there there are many in the party uh
that do not want you to be prime
minister you know that so i put it to
you that you're not a clean
well
look
thank you for the question and i think
it's important that we do whoever wins
this election does restore trust because
trust has been broken and we need to
rebuild all of that with the country
that's why it's something that i'm keen
to do as leader and i think i can do
that and it's about the conduct of
government which is important and you
can expect that that's the kind of
leadership i'll provide
but you know with regard to the
parliamentary party you can look around
you can see who's here what has really
humbled me and given me an enormous
amount of encouragement is the breadth
of support from people
from
from it's from all wings of the party
it's from all regions of the party and
that's why i believe i'm best placed to
bring the party back together but also
reunite the country because ultimately
that's the most important thing we want
to bring the country together and i
believe i can do that
[Applause]
some of the issues around your green
card your wife's non-dom tax status
these are going to be issues that labor
are going to be able to use against the
conservatives in the next election about
character of the prime minister aren't
they they're problems in your closet
well i mean we actually they've all
they're all out there and we've
discussed them and we addressed them in
easter i referred myself as you know to
lord guy who
wrote and described my behavior and
conduct as meticulous and there were
absolutely no conflicts or anything like
that and my wife made her own statement
at the time and i respect her decisions
to do that and i fully respect her
decisions going forward and of course i
will continue to ensure that we have
very high standards in public office
that's what people rightly should expect
from their leaders that's what i will
provide